back on the Internet's hi tell me about
that my producer was just like
whispering in my ear that you would
whispered into his ear about that 1934
picture in New York of the people yes a
rallying for the Nazis it's it's it's a
long-standing concern of the ACLU to
defend the rights of people that even
you hate right that freedom of speech is
for everyone
indivisible and that's for everyone and
so the very thing and that's very brave
of you it's the right thing to that's
true courage it's the right it's not
popular it's it's what I tell our folks
is that if we don't stand up for the
right of freedom of speech now for folks
that we hate right today's gonna be
black lives matter and the dreamers
right protesters who care about trans
right actually shut down but the very
first big Nazi case for us was in the
1934 the picture you showed on the show
where that was that was courageous I
mean the Skokie case is the best-known
one right but that was easier right sure
goki the Nazis were a pathetic little
group of individuals had never even had
the damn picket in in in Chicago in
Skokie actually and but in 1934 the
Nazis were on the ascent and they were
one yes down Broadway yeah and it's a
lot like the current context where the
UI's a white supremacist is on the
ascent that's me real yes and it's not
these are not just hallucinations by by
folks of color and by by religious
minority groups but I think it's
essentially it's really important for us
to do Chelsea Handler what do you think
of the right-wing media using your
actions to enrage their base are they
doing that to you I guess oh I don't
know I mean I don't you read your social
no I don't read anything I don't know
what people who do I can't ever imagine
sitting there and going on somebody
engages being like you I hate you doing
that so no I don't care what anybody
those people say I don't know how to
block people and when I do I'm gonna
start right
energy out there because that way it's
recorded you know any minute eventually
there will come a time where we will
tamp down on this behavior not through
freedom of speech but through some other
you know through some other legislation
because obviously this hateful rhetoric
all the time and threatening people's
lives through legislation it has to be
through restoring social norms right
need to be through restoring this word
that he has emptied of all meaning which
is civility civility matters he's taken
away all of the guardrails that's why
these bigots in their basement feel the
confidence and is mine to come out and
shoot people but I have to say it to
that point I've become such a kind or
nicer person because of Donald Trump
being elected and they hate you like I'm
nice to people I never noticed before
because I'm like oh my god this is what
happens if you don't pay attention to
other people around get out of your own
lane and pay attention to the people
around you I'm nicer in Kandra I'm doing
great okay for Barry and Jim going
forward will there continue to be a
place for an actual reporter like Shep
Smith oh yes at Fox News I don't know
how he's done it before - yes of the few
people him bret baier chris wallace
there's a few dana perino
but especially him he said about the
Carib and it's not a danger no one's
coming to get you let's see you back
there at Fox I mean it's Trump but he
doesn't watch that one I mean isn't
there something we can do I mean I don't
want to like I mean don't we want to we
have to hold Rupert Murdoch accountable
in some way I mean there's got to be a
creative way to squeeze those
advertisers on that network a lot of
liberal doesn't someone know Rupert
Murdoch and couldn't make a lot of
people know you probably know Roberta
I've met him I wouldn't say I know him I
didn't someone get to him and say Fox
has a board of directors that are all
immigrants by the way one of them was
born in this country I'm on the Fox News
Board I just read that today he had been
on the board there there are a lot of
folks because that's what's different is
that he has state TV yeah that's what we
never had before
that's what a dictator always has and
they're saying that they are bringing
the the migrants in the caravan are
bringing smallpox yes okay a disease
which has been eradicated so and people
you know watch this incessantly but
they're talking to get it funded State
Department on Lou Dobbs but I think
right if they get it right once in a
while when they let Chris Wallace say
the right thing in a certain slot we
have to put that in the context of the
rest of the time they're 24 hours in
which getting it's just like so we give
them a little bit dog biscuit thank you
for getting the news right this time I
know but come on I'm glad someone like
Shep Smith and Chris Wallace are gone
there because the people that are
watching it I want them to get a little
bit of sanity what are you better if
they weren't on there at all no of
course I don't think so but it doesn't
fix the problem doesn't argument for all
the people that are in the
administration keeping an eye on things
or staying the ship it's like well okay
but you guys aren't really doing a good
job of keeping it together either you
know okay would you a little bit I'm
happy that Jim mattis is there right now
I feel is safe and I already feel unsafe
if he wasn't there
right no I mean it's a lose-lose but I
think it's sort of unbalanced a little
better what do you make of people like
Lou Dobbs who used to be normal
it's not the Russians come on he's
getting to be a rock star yeah getting
the adulation of this mob yes okay and
people are giving in to that I saw him
in West Hollywood on Halloween he's
doing all right Thank You panel Thank
You audience vote please vote that's
[Applause]